je vais aller faire un tournoi de paddle
ah bah oui
P2000 c'est le gratin ça veut dire tu as
tous les meilleurs joueurs français et
maghrébins
donc j'arrive là-bas et je joue avec un
mec que je connais pas mon partenaire ça
plaît Mario
Mario en espagnol il parle pas un mot
français j'arrive de voir
ou chelou
je commence à
faire
ça tu vois
je joue avec lui il y avait une
traductrice pendant qu'on joue et on a
pris une traductrice qui était là c'est
une meuf l'espagnol et bien je suis pas
l'espagnol je suis bah moi aussi
ça suffira pour le match
je suis vraiment espagnol tout ça je
veux rester avec vous pour le match donc
elle nous colle tu vois non elle est là
je suis là je suis dans le pas je parle
au gars je dis ça va toi
[Rires]
[Musique]
des Français non mais je t'explique elle
nous suit la meuf tu vois Paola
on commence à jouer le match et là je
sais pas ce qu'il y a
la vérité il me met pas une balle dans
le cours
donc là il me parle tout le match il m'a
l'air là
en fait tu m'as cassé les couilles en
fait en fait arrête de me parler je
comprends pas ce que tu dis et tu es ta
voix m'énerve
et donc
il lui dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
apparemment on est au changement de côté
il y avait mon coach il a traductrice
donc là le coach il est druque et là et
l'autre tu dirais
faire un peu plus de l'Aube et bah tu
lui diras qu'avant de faire des notes
déjà
oui et là le mec il fait ouais
je te jure après je dis c'est une chèvre
dis-lui que c'est une chèvre et pourquoi
vous avez une chèvre pourquoi c'est une
chèvre comme ça et il dit
non il est très content de jouer avec
toi
c'est terminé donc on a fait les poules
c'est des poules il y a quatre équipes
on a terminé quatrième de la oh là là ah
les gens nous jetés
alors honnêtement j'ai pris j'ai jeté ma
raquette mais non j'ai jeté ma raquette
là il a raquette a rebondi elle a
faillite j'ai failli la mettre dans la
tête du coach il a pris la la ça aurait
été Hanouna est incontrôlable Hanouna
nous refait une nuit Boyard
ça aurait été un déferlement médiatique
ah vous avez pas tenu bonheur non j'ai
pris la raquette je l'ai cassé je suis
parti voilà donc là j'ai plus parler
espagnol moi je parle donc je pars la
meuf il vient jusqu'à ma voiture avec la
meuf à côté qu'est-ce que tu fais elle
me dit ouais
il faut savoir ce que tu fais ce soir
non mais ce soir
je fais rien ce soir ok on va rentrer
chacun dans son hôtel hein et tout le
monde sera content donc tu vas arrêter
de me gonfler les yox OK et là je dis il
est content il te voit ce soir
[Applaudissements]
c'était une contreperformance de ce
garçon ou est-ce que d'habitude il est
toujours mauvais ou est-ce que c'est
parce que c'était pas avec vous
la choisir
Mario et moi au début en plus je rigole
premier point il met les premiers points
il me fait une merde c'est pas super
Mario hein
tu me le renvoie à Barcelone à Madrid
c'est ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit ils m'ont
mis au frigo ah oui oui
ils ont joué sur le plus faible
mondial il est plus fort que moi 7
mondiales sur la tête de ma mère moi je
suis Jean-Pierre Foucault il a dit je
dis non
à chaque fois il a craqué hein ça
brûle on est d'accord c'est bon c'est un
Bruno et Sabrina
chef ça n'arrive pas ça arrive ça arrive
aux autres mais pas moi ça vous a énervé
vraiment beaucoup hein d'habitude